I'll go and get started uh good
afternoon and um I want to thank
everyone for being here today um we are
here
unfortunately uh because the union
representing a group of 180 supervisors
at
CNBC have set up picket lines at CNBC
facilities effectively shutting down the
bus system and Cs and disrupting the
lives of hundreds of thousands of people
in our region Coast Mountain bus company
was working hard to reach a compromise
with the union and prevent this all day
yesterday and Saturday through mediation
but unfortunately CNBC informs us that
the union continues to demand far higher
wage increases than their
colleagues this is disappointing and
frustrating this is unfair to our
customers the people of this region do
not deserve to be caught in the middle
of this
dispute over 300,000 people rely on the
bus system to get around Metro Vancouver
every single day that is a substantial
amount of this Region's population that
woke up this morning
stranded thousands of workers that
couldn't get to work at Health Care
Facilities dayare facilities Care Homes
retail stores offices construction sites
thousands of students that couldn't get
to postsecondary campuses and schools
thousands of extra cars on the
road look uh this dispute is between
CNBC and QP local 4500 but TransLink
overseas customer impacts and the
financial health of the
organization a
13.5% wage increase over three years was
accepted by all other CNBC unions bcrc
unions
and other public sector unions across
the province and I understand that CNBC
even improved on its original offer and
address the Union's demands regarding
workload
issues CNBC has advised us that the
union still wants significantly more
than any other Union has settled
for but I've got to say now is not the
time that's because at TransLink we are
facing a fiscal crisis I have been
transparent with the public over the
last year that TransLink is facing a
structural deficit of $4.6 billion over
the next 10 years we are feeling system
pressures our system is already
overcrowded our region is growing and it
is going to get
worse we estimate that the ripple effect
of the Union's demands on other future
contracts to be in the order of $250
million that is $250 million on top top
of a $4.6 billion deficit over 10
years look the fact is that cnbc's
Transit supervisors and maintenance
supervisors and tcom supervisors I I
know many of them they are good people
they work hard they do great work for
our customers and they keep our system
moving every single
day but this is not the time to be
fighting for significantly more than
what everyone else got I urge the
parties to return to the bargaining
table and to resolve the dispute because
this strike has too much impact on our
customers who count on us CNBC has
conveyed to me that they are ready and
willing at any time to get back to the
table and get a deal
done thank you so much I'm happy to take
any
questions what's the latest with the
Labor
Relations uh so my my understanding is
that uh a hearing has not been scheduled
at this time um we don't expect a
hearing to be Set uh for for today or
tomorrow and so as a result uh there
will not be any impacts to Sky Train
Expo Millennium Canada lines uh and West
Coast Express within the 48 hour
set yeah until the hearing
that's application yeah I think our
position is that we uh absolutely have
the right to inform our customers uh uh
of options that they have we have the
ability to inform our customers that um
Sky Train is available that other
services are available in the event uh
bus is not
available
anyone else in the room uh yeah just
wondering after this 48 hour period uh
do you have any idea what happens after
that are the supervisors planning to
return to work could they take more job
action in the future Beyond uh I think
that's a great question for uh for QP
4500 uh in terms of what their what
their plans are I would urge them to um
cease this strike action immediately and
the impacts that it's having to the
region um and the economy of this region
uh but in terms of their future plans I
think that's a good question for them I
I would strongly encourage uh both the
union and CNBC to get back to the
negotiating table and get a deal
done my understanding is that the 4500
is asking for aasis outline with what
other similar rules have requested what
would that mean for transl in terms of
additional cost need
to sure yeah it's a good question um so
so the waging um let me back up you know
at trans link we have a series of
operating companies Coast Mountain bus
company uh bcrc Sky Train and so uh
historically you know many of the unions
across the TransLink Enterprise do look
at other Union um negotiated agreements
for either formal met too Clauses or
even informally to ask for what other
members got uh and so we believe that
absolutely applies here that there would
be as a result of uh what the union has
asked for these Ripple effects that
would happen on other contracts that uh
in our estimation amount to $250 million
over a 10-year period again you know we
sit here today with a a coming out of
the pandemic a $4.6 billion deficit over
10 years we uh fortunately have been the
recipient of uh provincial and federal
government funding that has allowed us
to stay stable through the end of of
2025 but the fact is that it is uh not
financially responsible to dig that hole
any deeper and uh again I would
encourage the union to to uh accept a
fair and reasonable offer that CNBC has
put on the table that is uh fair and uh
you know equivalent to what they've uh
given to other unions and that they've
accepted if I can ask a followup
question briefly the Union's line has
been that while they're asking for a
bigger percentage they say they're
gaping what their supervisors what other
acoss system is that true you offer some
comparators are yeah I've got to say I
think it's a good question for CNBC it's
a pretty kind of detailed negotiating
question I think it's a good question
for CNBC sorry at what point are you
considering asking the government for
intervention of things like back work or
anything of that nature would you
consider that if they call another
strike or another stri yeah I'd say you
know we are in uh contact with the
province the province is uh very much on
top of this file and I think I share
their desire that both parties re-engage
come back to the negotiating table in
good faith and and reach a negotiated
agreement thanks we'll now go to
reporter on the
line Mike if you can hear hear us it's
your turn question
Mike you're
muted sorry about that um can you tell
me of that more than
300,000 daily bus riders how many are
commuters and then um QP 4500 just said
they want to bridge that
discrepancy uh in wages with other
supervisors other TransLink
supervisors um they need that wage
discrepancy closed so what are they
saying if you're saying that they're not
going to accept the the raises that
everyone else um has accepted
recently um would that raise still put
them below other TransLink
supervisors
yeah my my so I I don't have the
breakdown of commuters I mean those
300,000 people that are on our system
every day all of them are commuters
every single one of them is trying to
get around the region and commute
whether that's to to work or medical
appointments whatever it is right those
are 300,000 people on on that system and
so uh their lives are being disrupted
today by this strike action as it
relates to uh CNBC supervisors um they
uh my understanding is the union is
looking at at uh parody between the CNBC
supervisors and maybe this is what your
question was getting CNBC supervisors
and um Sky Train supervisors you know my
understanding from CNBC is that those
are two very different positions that
Sky Train supervisors essentially um
have a responsibility to hire fire and
manage employees Transit supervisors do
not hire fire or manage any employees
they're responsible to be out on the
system to manage incidents as they
happen um and uh to respond accordingly
and so I believe cnbc's position is that
these are these are two different
supervisory positions that um do not
have any
parody the next one and sorry just one
more oh one more followup before Atlanta
sorry Atlanta um can we um C if you've
answered this earlier apologies I
couldn't hear the question but if they
want to continue picketing uh say
Wednesday if talks don't progress would
would they have to apply again is it
your understanding they're allowed to do
that um I think that's a question for Q
in terms of uh uh what they would do
what they would do next I my
understanding is they could um at any
time announce any type of job action uh
for whatever period of time uh it's very
uh confusing and very disruptive to our
writers I'll jump in next I'm not sure
if this was asked because I couldn't
hear the questions but can you speak to
the sky train service I know there was
some confusion about that possibly not
operating later today could you just
speak to that sure so so the the reason
behind that had to do with a labor board
hearing um so that hearing uh would rule
upon whether uh Sky Train uh would be
impacted by not the fact is a hearing
has not been scheduled at this time and
so we don't expect a hearing to be set
for today or tomorrow and as a result
there will be no impact to Sky Train uh
Expo Millennium Canada lines or West
Coast Express
tomorrow thank
you no further questions online anybody
else in
the says that
one the says that one of other issues
Beyond just money is over CBC already
made some commit to hire more Transit
supervisors but I wonder if you can loan
some insight this why does this group of
employees feel so burn
out uh I can't speak to that that's a
good question for
CNBC is there a longterm plan uh on
behalf of TransLink and Co Mountain Buzz
company in the event that this job
action extends for an extended period of
time it's been a while but I think in
2001 it was six or eight weeks the bus
drivers were on strike and that
obviously caused incredibly major
economic disruption yeah I think uh at
this time we're we're planning on this
48 hour period and really focused on
that and being sure that our customers
um uh know what's going on we keep them
up to date uh you know again I'm
encouraging both parties really get back
to the table so that we don't have any
type of long-term uh dispute that's out
there
everybody
one M go
ahead
yeah thanks again um wanted to know if
you're ramping up any Sky train service
to try and um bridge that that Gap in in
bus routes or if you have any other
measures any other levers um that can be
pulled no my understanding is that uh no
bcrc has not increased any uh Sky train
service uh in response to the bus
strike great thank you
thank
you that's
awesome
hi thank you for coming
today my name is Liam O'Neal I'm
National representative for the Canadian
Union uh public
employees and uh representative also for
uh QB
4500 as you know QP 4500 members have
withdrawn services today from coast
Mountain
bus um QP 4500 has put in a solid effort
to to try to find compromise with Coast
Mountain QB 4500 has worked very hard at
trying to achieve a deal with Coast
Mountain at the table we've provided
compromise and
solutions and
um and in an effort
to avoid these service
disruptions we're not interested in
bargaining in the media
um and yet Coast Mountain bus um are
more seem more interested in assigning
blame and to smearing our members than
to getting a
deal we've worked very hard we just went
through over 20 hours of talks with
Coast mountain with the assistance of a
mediator and while we brought Solutions
and
compromise uh Coast Mountain
bus simply try to bully us into
accepting their
proposals there is a
longstanding uh wage discrepancy that
we're trying to
fix in
TransLink our
members do the same work as other
supervisors in TransLink and yet they're
paid less we need to fix that wage
discrep
and we're trying to do
that
we've as an example the
um additional cost to Coast Mountain bus
in order to fix that wage
discrepancy it would cost them annually
less than an additional
0.05% of their annual budget for salary
benefits and wages and yet they still
refuse to fix this wage
discrepancy our proposal package that
we've provided we believe is reasonable
and fair not only for our members but
for Coast
Mount thank
you uh so just an hour ago the CEO of
transing said that the advis positions
that you're seeking to be on par with
are different because the people in
those roles are responsible for hiring
firing and supervising people whereas
they say that the bus supervisors are
responsible for supervising incidents
and helping ensure the system is running
smoothly but not hiring firing and
supervising
staff well there yeah they're they're
trying to mince words here they're um
the supervisors that we're referring to
do not directly hire they're not in
charge of a make the decisions to hire
fire or
discipline um so but when you look at
the full job description and and what
they do um those no two jobs are
identical and yet the the job that the
supervisors do at 4500 is on par with
what they do in other uh areas of transl
what the general public seeing a a
request uh for % wage increase over 3
years um that doesn't seem realistic for
a lot of people in their own jobs uh how
do you justify that kind of request in
one threeyear period yeah so we've we've
never had a uh cross the board 25% wage
increase um the what again this is you
know we don't want to negotiate in the
media um what Coast mountain and or
TransLink put out as far as wages does
not reflect the discussions that
happened at the table um so I'll leave
that to them to answer
for earlier
Kevin said that the issue with granting
a wage increase supervisor that matri or
Mees and other contracts around trans
region he said he believes this will
cost 250 million over the next 10 years
um you put it you framed it terms the
cnbc's you know their expens but I
wonder how you respond to that argument
that increased a it does not have any
ripple effect at all there is no me too
clause for our supervisors so this again
is Coast mountain and or translate
trying to um play with words and try to
negotiate in the media when they know
full well there's no me to Clause at all
said earlier that it was not sure that
you look for a 25% wage increase across
years and I know that you're not
actually negotiating media but I wonder
if that statement was happen happenly
false are you seeking for example
practice compl against we're more
focused at trying to get a deal at the
table than to try to negotiate uh
through the media and uh we we're not
going to stoop to the tactics of Coast
mountain and we're not going to um fall
to their level of of uh how they like to
try to address things if they spent more
time trying to get a deal at the table
than to try to smear Us in public we'd
already have a
deal uh they say they're ready go back
to the table right now uh during this
period of job action are you prepared to
go to to negotiate when are you prepared
to go back to the table they say they're
ready to go right now yeah well I mean
they they say a lot of things um and we
we just at the table and like I said
there's no we're willing to go to the
table if they're willing to negotiate
but they're not they're not willing to
negotiate they just arrive at the table
and they try to bully us us into
accepting their proposal that's not how
you negotiate so sitting down at a table
and then just trying to bully the
proposals they have and and then
bringing no compromise or no Solutions
that'll never get us there if they have
Solutions and compromise we're willing
to sit down and look at that there's a
48 hour schedule for this job action at
the end of that period what happens next
from your perspective so we will
continue with her overtime ban and then
um clearly we don't have a deal now so
we'll have to plan our next escalation
obviously it's going to be uh an
escalation which means more than the
current one um and um I'm sure that
we'll be announcing something at some
point uh and as soon as we figure that
out we'll let you know can you talk
about your application to the Labor
Relations Court your complaint to them
uh and and what you are hoping to be
able to accomplish based on whatever
comes out of that yeah which which which
complaint we have a couple the one about
wishing to take it outside of in a more
broad range of areas right so we do have
a complaint in with the board um and
that's with the board right now and
we're waiting for uh that to go through
that process so we can't really comment
on that until we um until the board
hears it and um and so we're just going
to wait for that process to go through
why do you want to expand your
areas well if
you know it's a Ally application so
if um there's if you know if we're
successful then um TransLink and door
Sky Train would be acting as an ally to
Coast mountain and that we would have
that right so but again we're just going
to allow that to go through the process
and um let the board determine that you
said very C applications into the labor
board what's the other
one um the other one is a 68 so it's uh
using illegal replacement workers um so
but we're going
to you know we're going to let these
things work through what they work
through again we're we're just going to
allow that the process to happen there
and um can you expand on the substance
of that complaint though like I haven't
heard any
allegations yeah I I can't really uh I'm
not going to comment on that right now
we'll just let that go through the
process
I wonder what you would say to commuters
this morning some of whom I'm sure
support workers others who other you
know other people may have felt
inconvenienced may have felt erap the
fact they couldn't get to work in the
morning you say the general public yeah
again we've done everything we could our
members um they know they they the main
part of their job what they do every day
is to try to make sure that there's a
service that they provide to the public
and they're very proud of what they do
so having to take this action is not an
easy thing for us to do for our members
to do um again we've done everything we
could we did an overtime ban we've
provided compromise we went through
mediation but the this employer is just
unwilling
to uh deal with the issue of um the wage
discrepancy that exists and and we've
had no choice
So Co boss uses language like
unrealistic what go through yeah I
mean they say a lot of things um that
you know
we it it's realistic and it's fair to ex
to um and and it's easy to understand
that when workers from one group do the
same job job as they do in another group
they should be paid the same wages so if
they're saying it's unrealistic to be
paid fairly that that's fine let I'll
let them say that and I'm more focused
on trying to get a deal at the table and
I'd love for them to um address our
issues okay thank you very much for
joining us they will be could introduce
say spell your name it's Liam O'Neal and
last name can you spell it
o apostrophe n e i l l perfect thank you
you're
welcome